the democrats effort to expand voting
rights could collapse in the senate
tonight this bill has no republican
support and is expected to fail
senate democratic leader chuck schumer
plans to propose changing the rules so
the bill can be blocked by a so-called
talking filibuster but he doesn't appear
to have the votes to pass it scott
mcfarland is on capitol hill with more
on this story scott good morning to you
good morning gail after months of
marches meetings and maneuverings the
senate could vote today on this sweeping
new voting rights bill but without the
support of two moderate senate democrats
kirsten cinema of arizona and joe
manchin of west virginia to change
senate rules it appears destined to fail
and that is angering many of their
colleagues
you better stand up
because
if you don't
they're coming after your rights next
democrats are moving forward in an
effort to put all senators on the record
on the issue of voting rights their bill
among other things would allow for early
and no excuse mail in voting across the
country and make election day a federal
holiday it faces almost certain defeat
their cataclysmic predictions
for failing to support their entirely
partisan election reform
worked out entirely by themselves
without any input whatsoever from any
single person on my side of the aisle
they're far beyond the pale the proposed
legislation would also make it harder
for states to stiffen requirements for
voter id
[Music]
that's exactly what's just been formally
proposed in michigan where the reverend
charles williams is knocking on doors
and telling voters to oppose the plan
for michigan republicans to tighten
voter i.d rules generations to come
will
say
my father my grandfather
worked hard
to protect my right to vote michigan's
democratic secretary of state says she's
like congress to pass the new federal
law today throughout history we've seen
the critical need for the federal
government to be a partner in the team
that protects democracy but the state's
republicans say these matters are best
left to states to decide that is one of
the top things that they talk to me
about is what are you doing
to ensure that our elections are fair
and here on capitol hill some extra
pressure on one of those two holdout
senators joe manchin of west virginia
who says he won't change senate rules in
a letter alabama football coach nick
saban and nba hall of famer jerry west
asked senator manchin to reconsider
coach saban mr west both native sons of
west virginia gail
certainly getting a lot of high powered
pressure thank you very much scott